thanks blinkist for sponsoring this
video
one minute you're setting up a new space
station orbiting Jupiter the next you're
plunging right into the middle of a
giant Red Cyclone of death
what would the storm of all storms look
like on the inside
how would it compare to storms back on
Earth
and which one of Jupiter's tremendous
forces would strike the lethal blow
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into Jupiter's Great
Red Spot
the Great Red Spot is the biggest storm
in the solar system
at about 16 300 kilometers wide well
it's large enough to swallow the Earth
whole
it's a lot like a hurricane only instead
of lasting a few weeks this giant storm
has been rampaging for at least 300
years
and instead of forming from warm air
this monstrosity gets its energy from
the dense atmosphere of Jupiter
fueled by an abundance of the planet's
hydrogen and helium
the Great Red Spot reaches 500
kilometers into its atmosphere
oops we should have built that space
station a little further away
that's okay I think you know we're not
going to end this here I'll tell you
more in a minute but first hey this year
is about being the best version of you
you can be and blinkist is here to help
blinkist is an app that gives you the
core ideas from over 5500 non-fiction
books and podcasts in just 15 minutes
not 5 500 in 15 minutes you get the core
ideas from one book in 15 minutes but
you have over 5500 to choose from and
these aren't book reports it's
tremendous insight into some of the most
mind-blowing content available plus
blinkist offers an extraordinary audio
experience as well right now I'm
listening to alien thinking which lays
out the five critical skills to help
anyone innovate on demand we hear it
what if no from experience that
Innovation is the key to success for any
business and since I'm a premium
subscriber I can use blinkist connect
which allows me to share my account with
another team member a friend or whoever
I want that's two accounts for the price
of one get 25 off blinkist premium when
you sign up today start your seven day
free trial by clicking the link below
the inspiration you need is just a click
away which is much closer than the red
spot
okay well first how on Earth would you
even get to Jupiter
well if you traveled light and followed
the root of the Voyager spacecraft you'd
arrive on Jupiter in just under 600 days
but this journey wouldn't be as simple
as just pointing yourself at what
appears to be a very bright star in the
night sky
roaming the solar system in a spaceship
is a little more complicated than that
hey you see the Voyager never intended
to land on Jupiter only to pass it on
the way to Interstellar space
so if you followed voyager's path you'd
whip right past your target
for this to work you'd need to follow
the lead of the Galileo spacecraft
launched in 1989
just like Galileo you'd swing by Venus
and then back around Earth for a little
gravity assist
this way you'd have the right speed to
park in Jupiter's orbit
only the trip would now take you six
years instead of 600 days
by the time you reached Jupiter's moon
Europa the planet would appear 22 times
larger to you than a full moon did back
on Earth
and you'd still need to get a little
closer
now you'd be mesmerized by the planet's
Swirls and Stripes
these are colored red brown and white
thanks to the sunlight reflecting off
massive clouds made of ammonia and
ammonium sulfide
finally you'd Feast your eyes on the
Great Red Spot a giant twirl of the
atmosphere rotating counterclockwise it
looks a lot bigger than you could
imagine
but before you even begin your descent
into the great red unknown your life
would already be in grave Danger
Jupiter's powerful magnetic field would
shower you with intense radiation
I mean luckily you'd be equipped with a
highly Advanced protective suit but it
wouldn't be able to protect you from
everything
as you approached the storm you'd
realize that you made a big mistake in
your mission prep
your plan was to build your space
station at the same altitude as the
International Space Station
400 kilometers into Jupiter's atmosphere
yeah except this storm is as deep as 40
Mariana trenches
so it would swallow you up before you
could finish your project
ah but now it's too late you'd be
plummeting through the storm and you'd
get your first real glimpse of how
powerful it is
you'd be thrown around at wind speeds of
about 400 kilometers per hour
to give you a sense of how insanely
powerful that would be hurricanes are
ranked into five categories based on
strength a category one storm has wind
speeds up to 153 kilometers per hour
strong enough to snap large trees
in the middle a category 3 hurricane can
hit 208 kilometers per hour
these storms could result in devastating
damage including pulling roofs right off
of houses
lastly a category 5 hurricane back on
Earth has wind speeds of 252 kilometers
per hour or higher
that packs enough of a punch to collapse
buildings but that's still only half as
strong as the winds in the Great Red
Spot
thankfully your body can withstand wind
gusts as high as 800 kilometers per hour
but that doesn't mean it would be
refreshing in any way
without the protective face gear your
skin would look as if it was melting
straight off of your fridge
so make sure to hold on to that helmet
tight
not that you'd be able to do much else
besides staying on a violent downward
trajectory at this point
as you were falling into Jupiter you'd
see how clouds around you would change
first you'd get a real close-up view of
those ammonia and ammonium sulfide
clouds you were mesmerized by before
then you'd pass through clouds made of
water just like the ones on Earth
the temperature and pressure all around
you would be changing too
if sadly none of this would be
comfortable for you especially not at
the same time
where the atmospheric pressure is
similar to that of sea level back on
Earth it would be a very chilly minus
110 degrees Celsius
and where the temperature was bearable
the pressure would be eight times
greater than what it was back on Earth
now the chances of surviving up to this
point would be slim I mean look no
further than the Fate suffered by the
Galileo probe as it descended further
and further into Jupiter it encountered
extremely high temperatures
and what do you think happens to a probe
in that environment
yeah it vaporizes
without a space suit strong enough to
withstand all that heat and pressure
you'd end up disintegrating just like
the probe
now you'll be one with the gas giant
forever
but hey things could be worse I mean you
could have fallen into a black hole
but that's a story for another
what if